il était tellement content d'avoir un
garçon
puis quand il a vu les autres bébés
marché n'est pas le ciel a commencé à
son fermi
il a arrêté la compétition
en fait ça fait des années qu'ils
s'éloignent de mu
il a besoin d'un père tu comprends ça
moi je m'occupe tous les jours depuis 17
ans matin midi et soir territoire 3 km
de natation 180 km de vélo et 42 km à
pied
ça c'est une course d'hommes on peut
faire l'aéronef quoi
c'est quoi cette idée sur la pomme si je
veux arriver une crise assez non j'en
suis pas capable tutoriel ça de la tête
trouva bien non je rien perdu
d'abord donne pas trop
que ce
concentré en permanence pas une seconde
d'inattention sinon c'est le gala
farid et ses profits c'est trop
dangereux
ce n'est pas grave si on finit pas si
c'est grave bon je vais aller au bout
avec toi